Democratic Education is based on the belief
that children themselves know best
what is good for them.
The job of a school is to provide a democratic structure
in which kids can discover their interests
and learn how to live in a community
that solves conflicts together.
The ideal: to grow up in absence of fear and
to become responsible,
empathic and self-determined citizens.
The idea is not new.
In 1693 the philosopher John Locke wrote that
"things children learn, should never be
a burden to them."
Some 200 years later
the writer Leo Tolstoy opened a school for peasant children on his estate in Russia.
The school evolved from ideas introduced
by teachers and pupils.
One of the principles was that the students had the right to not listen to the teacher.
The first democratic school that still exists,
is Summerhill in Suffolk, England.
It was founded in 1921 by A.S. Neill
who believed that a school should be made for the child, rather than the other way around.
Class attendance is voluntary.
Some children may spend weeks in the woods
or do nothing all day,
while others choose to learn math
or try out reading class.
When they grow older many turn to traditional subjects with full focus
when they realise that they need them
for college entrance exams.
At weekly school meetings,
staff and students gather to solve conflicts.
Once a conflict is brought to the meeting,
everybody in the school can speak up, mediate
or come up with a solution.
After the conflict was discussed and democratically processed,
harsh feelings are often buried and staff
and students leave peacefully.
The meetings are also used to work on the school regulations
and anybody can make a proposal for
a change of the rules.
If one student requests a change,
members discuss and then decide by popular vote whether the new idea will be implemented.
Sometimes the kids may vote
for the abolishment of all rules.
But after a few days of total chaos,
students usually use the same democratic process to  re-implement order.
Almost as if they all naturally seek structure.
In the 1960s young educators from all over
took inspiration from Summerhill and opened so called “free schools”.
One was the Sudbury Valley School which was founded in Massachusetts, United States.
Sudbury took the ideals of a democratic education even further.
Once a year the school meeting is used to re-elect teachers and principals.
Those that don’t receive majority vote will be replaced.
Today there are many independent Sudbury and other democratic schools
all over the world spanning from Brazil to Israel to Thailand.
Using different structures,
they all promote the idea that students and teachers should have an equal say in what to learn
and how to work with each other.
The goal is to give children a deep sense for equality and justice.
Albert Einstein famously said: “The only thing that interferes with my learning is my education”.
What do you think,
would a democratic education work for you?
Please share your thoughts in the comments below!